NORTH KOREAN BALLISTIC MISSILE.
IT WAS THE SECOND FAILURE OF THE
ANTIBALLISTIC MISSILE
AT GUANTANAMO BAY CUBA OPEN FOR
BUSINESS.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA SPENT
EIGHT YEARS TRYING TO CLOSE IT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US THAT
MEANS SUSPECTS COULD BE SENT TO
GITMO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN TEN
YEARS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO LOAD IT UP
WITH BAD DUDES.
DECISION TO CLOSE
GUANTANAMO BAY.
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION SAID
TERRORIST USE AS A RECRUITING
TOOL.
IT WAS AMONG PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
FIRST EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
>> GUANTANAMO WILL BE CLOSED NO
LATER THAN ONE YEAR FROM NOW.
LAST NIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SIGNED A NEW EXECUTIVE ORDER
BEFORE CHRISTMAS 90 DAYS TO
RECOMMEND WHETHER THOSE CAPTURED
ON THE BATTLEFIELD SHOULD BE
>> TERRORISTS ARE NOT MERELY
COMBATANTS.
WHEN CAPTURED OVERSEAS, THEY
SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE THE
TERRORISTS THEY ARE.
GITMO OPEN.
>> I THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT
SHOWED A DETERMINATION AS
COMMANDER IN CHIEF TO WIN A WAR
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE.
>> THAT'S GOING TO BE USED BY
EVERY TERRORIST GROUP WORLDWIDE
AGAINST US.
>> GUARDED BY 1500 U.S. TROOPS,
41 PRISONERS REMAIN AT
GUANTANAMO BAY, AMONG THEM
ALLEGED 9/11 PLANNER KHALID
SHEIKH MOHAMMED.
730 DETAINEES HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED TO 59 COUNTRY SINCE
2002.
122 FORMER DETAINEES RETURNED TO
THE BATTLEFIELD.
>> IN THE PAST, WE HAVE
FOOLISHLY RELEASED HUNDREDS AND
ONLY TO MEET THEM AGAIN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
INCLUDING THE ISIS LEADER
AL-BAGHDADI.
>> FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
CLOSE GITMO SAY TERRORISTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE CONVICTED IN A
FEDERAL COURT.
>> THE SHOE BOMBER, THE
UNDERWEAR BOMBER, THE BOSTON
MARATHON BOMBERS ALL TRIED IN
FEDERAL COURT, ALL CONVICTED,
NOT A SINGLE SECURITY INCIDENT.
>> BECAUSE THE U.S. TAX PICKER